well friends I hope July has treated you
well because we're about to move into a
whole new month good news is that August
means a bunch of new free games coming
for PlayStation Plus subscribers so
let's check them out first up on ps4 is
mafia 3 the open-world crime game stars
Vietnam veteran Lincoln clay on a
mission to take down the Mafia that
wiped out his entire family you can
explore the beautiful city of New
Orleans as you take your less than
beautiful revenge for the horror fans
ps4 is also getting dead by daylight
this asymmetrical multiplayer game puts
you in the shoes of killers like Michael
Myers and Freddy Krueger as everyone
else plays teens trying to survive the
night but wait there's more Sony is
giving away two other freebies the first
is here they lie a psvr horror game set
in a world full of creepy monsters
that'll be free for PS Plus subscribers
from August 7th through October 2nd the
second game knowledge is power uses
Sony's Play link app letting everyone
play with just their smartphones this
tactical trivia game will be available
from August 7th through November 6
moving the ps3 bound by flame is perfect
for the action RPG crowd letting you
explore skill trees for fighter Ranger
and Pyromancer that's all in service of
the fire demon who possesses you but
luckily his powers are perfect for
battling the ice Lords that have taken
over the land if you'd rather just shoot
your way to victory there Serious Sam 3
vfe the series is known for massive
hordes of enemies and this entry is no
exception the only difference is that
this time you'll be gunning them down in
22nd century egypt betta fans can get
their ninja on withdrawal slasher in
this action game you control protagonist
Hanzo entirely with the touchscreen you
can draw lines to move jump and attack
and pinch the screen to unleash powerful
ninjutsu finally more strategic Vita
owners can dig into space Hulk this
turn-based game is set in the Warhammer
40k universe putting you in control of a
small squad of Space Marines you'll need
to be smart if you hope to survive the
derelict spaceship they're exploring
and those are your free PS plus games
for August they'll be available from
Tuesday August 7th until September 3rd
remember that you can always check out
gameplay clips and reviews for these
titles on GameSpot be sure to stick with
us as we report on the newest PS plus
games every month
you
[Music]